great home cooking is built around
classic dishes
everyone's got their favorites from
super simple breakfast
to traditional sunday roast the secret
is not to let your classics go stale
make sure you keep your cooking exciting
by tweaking and adapting it
here are some of my ultimate classics
dishes we couldn't do without an air
house but
given delicious new twists first i
turned the quintessentially british
breakfast of baldegan soldiers
on its head next my eclectic wholesome
take on a classic plainman's lunch
ham or cheese or stilton it's hard to
dictate which one's the best
i'm gonna put all three in my eldest
megan helps me rust up a new spin on a
classic roast beef with yorkshire pud
pretty amazing it's incredible there
nice big chunks
lovely and we get stuck in to make an
unconventional eaten mess
oh okay come on wrangle my eyes these
are my classic dishes with a twist
breakfast lunch and dinner first
family favorite boiled eggs with a
soldier that will make your taste buds
stand to attention
there's something quite nostalgic about
a bald egg it's something that's never
lost
it's magic when you slice that top off
and dunk that soldier into the yolk
you can't mess with a deliciously runny
yolk but this
is what i like to dunk in it an anchovy
soldier anchovies interpersonal water no
salt
naturally yeah anchovies are very salty
so just a touch of pepper
rich in omega-3s the amazing tinned
anchovy is a natural flavor enhancer and
i use it to pepper many a savory dish
from roast lamb to the humble toasted
soldier
grind them it's a really nice
smooth paste the smell of that is almost
like being at the seaside
now get your soft butter and just put
half the butter in first
50 50 is the way if you send anchovy
pretend butter
that way you got that real nice salty
creaminess mix that up
that's absolutely delicious trust me
finishing that anchovy butter
on a slice of grilled fish i'm in heaven
the bread
this is a sourdough delicious very
crusty
take four nice slices
now get that pan nice and hot a couple
of tablespoons of that
anchovy oil into the pan and then get
your bread
and lightly fry each side
the smell of the anchovy oil is
incredible
take that out
now bring your water up to the boil the
secret of softly boiling an egg
is to place them into the water gently
on a spoon
in and just tilt so they don't hit the
bottom
nice and light up to the ball
count to five turn the gas down is it
four and a half minutes is it five
minutes for a softball day
i've cooked thousands of them and every
time
it's four and a half minutes whilst
that's boiling get your bread
and spread that on there that is
incredible
chopped parsley brings that kind of
freshness goes brilliantly well
with the anchovies
hear that crunch on
inside but i can't resist
oh my god right gas off
one beauty in
two i feel like a five-year-old again
this is that moment when you open the
vault and that little magic
inside is all yours
there's a great twist on a great classic
wow
[Music]
perfectly soft boiled eggs with dressed
up anchovy butter soldiers
who would have thought that egg and
soldiers could be that delicious
[Music]
classic recipes tend to be made with
ingredients we all know very well
but however familiar they are it always
pays to hunt out the very best
here are a few tips when you buy the key
ingredients for today's lunch
and dinner recipes
first off what could be more classically
british than the cheese that's been
produced here
since the 12th century cheddar
originally made in the caves of the
cheddar gorge in the west country
it's still far and away the uk's cheese
of choice
in britain cheddar outsells all the
other cheeses combined
good quality cheddar has an amber yellow
hue and it's firm
but not greasy or hard
river beef is the classic granddaddy of
all roasting joints
its generous marbling of fat keeps this
flavoursome meat moist
and succulent as a rule of thumb one rib
should generously feed two mouths
to feed my rabble for dinner tonight
i'll be needing a three rib joint
no roost beef dinner is complete without
the nose tingling delight
that is horse radish sauce a member of
the mustard family
this root is related to wasabi broccoli
and cabbage but looks more like a
knobbly parsnip
for dinner tonight i'm gonna break with
tradition and give my yorkshire pud
batter
a delicious horseradish kick
[Music]
a dish becomes a classic because it's
delicious and somehow strikes a cord
with us
it just works sometimes these dishes can
become tired
but a clever twist helps make them fresh
again
you can't get more classic than a
centuries-old midday meal of bread
cheese and beer reinvented and marketed
by pubs as a plan was launched in the
60s
i'm now giving it my 21st century take
like plummets with the most amazing but
super simple beer baked bread
hearty and full of flavor for a really
quick and easy bread dough
sieve a mix of wholemeal and
self-raising white flour with a good
pinch of salt
salt is really important the bread it's
the first thing i do once i've cracked
it and smelled
you want to smell that salt baked
throughout
beer in about 250 mils of beer
[Music]
the reason why this recipe works so well
is it the beer it's got that yeast
so naturally it's gonna work beautifully
give that a really good mix
i'm looking for the mixture to be quite
wet if the dough
becomes too firm then it's going to cook
dry in the center
just as it starts to fall through the
whisk that is perfect
beautiful this mix will work really well
as one large loaf but
i want to make my plan ones a little bit
more special
small tins give it that kind of intimacy
and i quite like
having my own little loaf give the molds
a really nice
lining with butter make sure you butter
the top
now a tablespoon of flour dust inside
the mold
that will stop your mixture sticking
tap out any excess three quarters fill
your little molds
we're going to allow it to sort of rise
just so it comes above
the mould and forms this really nice
miniature loaf
onto the tray a centimetre apart into
the oven
25 to 30 minutes at 180.
something quite nice about the smell of
home baked bread in the kitchen
delicious
no plan was it's complete without
pickled onions
red onion is a lot sweeter less harsh
than a white onion
the early days of plum ones
you've got those ghastly sharp pickled
onions that
make you almost cry when you're
crunching them i'm gonna lightly pickle
my red onion
just push your fingers through so you
get these nice sort of onion rings
a little touch of salt a little sprinkle
of sugar
and then a couple of cloves in there
that gives it a really nice sort of
perfume
and sort of makes the pickling slightly
more mellow
red wine vinegar now if you haven't got
red wine vinegar white wine vinegar it's
just as good but red
matches the red onion so it goes hand in
glove a couple of tablespoons
of vinegar just give that a really good
mix to speed up the pickling process
use a weight to put pressure on the
onions
as the weight presses down on the onions
the clove the salt the sugar the vinegar
work their magic
it comes out with a really nice light
fragrant pickle
for my 21st century ploughmans i'm
creating an all-in-one salad and
bringing the traditional elements
together with a punchy dressing
a tablespoon of english mustard a
tablespoon of honey
a touch of salt and pepper and finish
off with white wine vinegar and olive
oil
[Music]
now generally it's sort of three parts
oil to one part vinegar
that's the sort of general base
[Music]
you don't really think of a vinaigrette
with a plan ones but this is a really
nice sort of modern
approach to ploughmans for my plan one
salad i'm using a mixture of robust and
crunchy romaine lettuce
and punchy watercress if i was making a
watercress soup i'd use the stalks
but the stalks are a little bit bitter
so i just grab them like that pinch them
and then twist
very peppery very hot but so juicy
watercress in your celery chop it
nice and finely it's the one thing that
everybody leaves is that stick of celery
so
scatter it amongst the salad
a bit of oomph and color from some
sliced radishes and sweetness from a
thinly sliced apple
whilst you're busy throwing your plum
and salad together do not forget about
your beer bread
before it comes out i'm gonna glaze the
top with a little touch of milk
that'll put a really nice finish to the
bread back in for the last five minutes
now for the magic and the plum ones
generally you'd see it as a ham or
cheddar
or stilton flourman's it's hard to
dictate which one's the best
so for the ultimate plowmans i'm adding
all three
with your cheddar peel some nice shards
of that
delicious creamy cheddar just get them
dancing on top
the dressing drizzle ran in circles
and then finally our delicious
lightly pickled onions give them a good
squeeze
and look just dot the onions around
bread it's ready
it's got that nice yeasty smell
warm crusty and delicious
there you go that is my classic modern
version
of a traditional stunning playerman's
wow my delicious all-in-one plan one
salad
with individual beer bread loaves
updated for the 21st century
[Music]
i think a fantastic sunday roast is the
cornerstone of home cooking
it's what the rest of the week's meals
are built around and i
absolutely love it but that doesn't mean
it can't be improved
to make the most out of my roast my main
course is the delicious stuffed
roast rib of beef complete with tangy
horseradish yorkshire puddings
[Music]
but first i'm enlisting the help of my
eldest 15 year old megan to reinvent one
of my all-time favorite classic desserts
eaton mess bomb right
eat a mess what's the one thing you love
about user mess i love the meringues
now this is a eaten mess with a twist
what's the twist in it compared to the
normal one we're gonna freeze it so it's
almost like a sort of eaten mess bomb
wow now i'd like you to whisk the cream
please
half the strawberries are going to go
through the mix and half the
strawberries are going to be
turning to acouy strawberries in first a
little dusting of icing sugar
into the pan and now the icing sugar
will withdraw the sweetness from the
strawberries and start caramelizing so
let me show you a nice quick way of
whisking
secret whisking is like 10 seconds long
and 10 seconds off that way your arms
don't get tired
now i'm gonna take the cream to a
three-quarter stage
what is a three-quarter mix so we leave
some sort of texture
in the cream and that's what we call
three-quarter whip
you've got a nice soft peak
they're caramelized there you go you put
a little touch of water in there
that'll help break down the sugar
and turn that into a really nice
strawberry liquid
now to get it really nice and fine i'm
going to blend it
on and blitz
off okay that's fine i want you to use
the back of the spoon
and push that through the sieve okay
now that way you don't get those seeds
it smells so good i love this now
nice this is the exciting part hold up
oh meg don't tell us
right now the meringue will your fingers
just crush and flake the meringue into
the cream
how big should i crash it daddy there
nice big chunks okay lovely
oh you okay yeah got me wrong in my eye
damn
to make this dessert even easier i often
cheat by using good quality shop port
meringues
a little taste that's just cream and
rain
wow it's a little tasty okay
strawberries in next a couple of spoons
of the cooling
now look at that now to prepare the mold
to transform the traditional eaten mess
into a frozen bomb
form a triple layer of clim film
adding water to the bowl will help the
clim film stick
as i pour that in i want you to spread
it down okay at the bottom
and push it down can you hear that
crunch yeah the line
all right now
fold the clin film over put that in the
freezer please
meg young please in the freezer she goes
[Music]
dessert done now for our main course
with a twist that
is the rib eye we've had that in the
fridge
not wrapped so it sort of almost air
dries and it intensifies the flavor
gross so much quicker and there's less
water in the beef
for me the only downside to perfect
roast dinner is the fight about who
washes up afterwards
so meg and i are going to avoid that by
cooking everything in one roasting tin
starting with the spinach and mushroom
stuffing
[Music]
a little bit of salt and pepper please
here we go
some of your left shoulder some left
shoulder thank you in with the garlic
and the mushrooms toss the pan you push
down
and pull back down and push back off you
go
take your time push it down and flip it
back good that's it push down
nice this that was lovely and again nice
i'm gonna drop let's see well done well
done well then right we're gonna sort of
make a little well a little touch of
butter in the middle
now we need to start putting the spinach
in the middle please
so you can push that down the spinach is
cold so you're not going to burn
yourself
be confident in the pan toss it and
you'll see it
wilting and disintegrating away wow
people thought all that spinach could
fit in this pan because it's a very
delicate leaf
it sort of cooks so quickly put this all
on your board now
and then i just want you to go and give
that
a nice chop then when you're confident
with one hand
we need to pick up the other knife the
other hand
chop it nicely good
now outside and come in gently good
regroup and take your time
yes mmm right
i love that smell what is that lemon
thyme lemon tan that's right so you get
your
little thyme stalks and you pour down
you sort of
strip lemon thyme in now tarragon
no taste brilliant with the beef
fantastic with chicken and fish
roughly chop the target and i sprinkle
in fresh breadcrumbs
so the breadcrumbs almost sort of bring
the stuffing together
next we're gonna get an egg yolk now
with the beef
this is the exciting part slice
with the bone and then come inside and
go two thirds of the way down
hold that open for daddy salt and pepper
and then look we pack our stuffing in
there
this is amazing it's incredible now just
gently hold out there like that
okay yeah i'll see you tomorrow what
tying string around the rib will keep it
all together during roasting
not too tight if we tie it too tightly
what happens the stuffing will come out
that's right that's ready for roasting
but we're going to protect it
and sit it on a trivet
so trivet basically is almost like a
sort of little little bed a little bed
that's right if you want to enjoy these
delicious roast vegetables at their best
make sure you remove them from the hot
oven after 35 minutes
and reheat before serving with your beef
now a little mix for the top a couple of
teaspoons
of mustard powder in salt a couple of
tablespoons of olive oil
mix that in i'm gonna pour
my mustard powder over the beef so this
forms a really nice
glaze my one pot roast dinner goes into
a hot oven
15 minutes at 230 degrees then down to
170 degrees for another two hours
for a delicious twist on traditional
yorkshire puds i'm gonna lace mine with
fresh horseradish
start with plain white flour in a bowl
and crack in the eggs
adding only half of your milk at this
stage makes it much easier to whisk
all the lumps out and if like me you
like your puddings a little lighter and
crispier add a dribble of cold water
and add salt to season when you're happy
your batter is lump free
whisk in the remaining milk peel and
grate horseradish
and add a handful to the mix we can
leave the batter to rest
while we get the meat from the oven that
is beautiful
and this is where you really need to let
it rest how long would you say to rest
it for
um i like to rest the meat for at least
20 minutes
just the right amount of time for us to
whack up the oven and to get our
yorkshire puddings in
i love using the rich dripping but best
of all is a healthier option
to get the fluffiest yorkshires your
tray and fat must be piping hot
for best results take your jug of batter
to the oven and pour the mixture in
there
it takes just 15 minutes for our
yorkshire puds to puff themselves up
and turn a delicious golden brown with
the yorkshire puddings on the way
and the beef rested we can finish off
the eater mess bomb
run the bowl under the hot water
twist and pull nice wow
look at that beauty it's amazing sit
that
on to your plate now the finishing
touches
a drizzle of the remaining strawberry
coulee i'm just gonna pour this over
amazing flavor and some grated mint
chocolate
and that is a nice twist on a classic
eaten mess
a delicious eaten mess bomb
beautiful let's go baby please don't
drop that egg
meg please it's not around us match
dessert sorted and the beef is ready to
serve up
lift that up place that onto the board
parsnips parrots you can see why we kept
them in halves
they've got all that flavor one
beautiful big slice
for daddy one for maggie and then
on the side the stuffing the stuffing a
bit that's
the best to die for now fantastic
yorkshire amazing aren't they beautiful
mm-hmm
that's for you my daddy and that one
that's for me
beautiful roast beef with a twist
wow these
are my ultimate classics with a twist
juicy river beef with horseradish spiked
yorkshire puts
and scrummy eaten mess bomb topped with
strawberry coulee
and mint chocolate with the younger kids
out at friends
it's down to just me tana and megan to
get stuck in
that is a rib-eye fit for a king
oh wow that's cooked beautifully thank
you thank you
explain the moment what's in the
stuffing please daddy the stuffing has
mushrooms
lemon thyme tarragon and spinach
favorite part mate what'd you enjoy i
really enjoyed doing the stuffing
it's not as hard as it looked bon
appetit
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app
cook with me you can find it in the app
store good luck
you